Khalid Osman is an engineer who lost his
mother Dr nagua Khalid hamadan hatum
wearing fragments from shelling hit her
home he joins us from Silver Spring
Maryland first of all I just want to
pass on our sincere condolences to you
and your entire family and thank you
very much for for joining us on Al
Jazeera first of all can you just tell
us a little bit about the circumstances
of your mother's death
thanks so much for your thoughtful words
and uh
my mom my mom passed away on the 16th of
April uh the morning of Sunday at about
7 36 in the morning
she was actually at her house in the
living room
trying to take shelter over there
when uh a southern motor
landed Radix at their house and
she she called one of the shop Mills
that came from the motor and died almost
immediately my dad was with her at that
moment and he's a doctor as well he's a
he's a gynecologist and he was trying to
perform First Aid on her
sadly her head was too severe her
injuries was too severe to save
and she passed away immediately
I'm so sorry to to hear that is your
father gone back to work because we know
that they're uh you know this is turning
into a health emergency as much as
anything else with a shortage of doctors
and and the facilities to actually care
for for others do you know what he is
doing at this point in time
that's what I keep hearing as well but
it's it is it was almost impossible for
my dad to bring my mom's body
outside of the house of the hospital
itself because they were just shooting
people randomly over there as much as I
heard my dad was stuck at his house with
the windows broken and everything every
glass of it they shattered he couldn't
leave the house with because my brother
and my sister is over there as well
he's not able to leave the house and all
this we heard your mother was an
extremely generous woman can you explain
what type of doctor she was and and how
her patients will remember her
my mom
my mom was an angel she was she was so
compassionate she loved her patients she
loved everyone she never spoke ill of
everyone or anyone uh
one day I was with her in the hospital
and I remember one of her patients not
just one actually several of them they
didn't have enough money to pay for the
consultation or anything so they would
just bring her small bags of gift of
like lemonade or or a guava or any kind
of fruit or like just a single item
she would never turn away any patient
and she always like worked on her
patients with a smile and she was she
was so kind she was just she looks an
angel and uh going through Twitter and
the social media and just seeing the
words of the people
that wrote anything about her
there was just a lot of people I didn't
even know them honestly I still don't
know them but they were just a lot of
people
saying their condolences yeah to my mom
thank you so much for joining us and
once again our sincere condolences to
you and and your entire family
thank you
thank you so much I appreciate it I just
want to remind people to stay safe
inshallah and stay indoors and my mom
was a martyr and hopefully inshallah
she'll be in heaven by now okay Khalid
Osman speaking to us from Silver Spring
Maryland thank you very much